ко
Ось так гатять атакаamс вже в Україні
головнокомандувач ЗСУ Валерій залужний
оприлюднив це відео зі словами подяки
партнерам за підтримку було завдано
ударів по двох аеродромах в окупованих
Росією Луганську і Бердянську та знищено
гелікоптери і іншу техніку
росіян Дякую усім хто воює і працює
заради України Дякую усім хто допомагає
і с сгодні особлива вдячність сполученим
штатам наші домовленості з президентом
байденом
виконуються виконуються дуже влучно
атакамси себе показали Слава
Україні за даними американських ЗМІ
протягом останніх кількох днів США
відправили в Україну невелику кількість
далекобійних ракет атакамс доставляли їх
таємно через побоювання що вантаж може
бути атакований Росією під час ввезення
в країну крім того Україна планувала
застати росіян з ненацька The New York
Times посилаючись на двох західних
посадовців стверджує що Україна отримала
близько 20 ракет атакамс одна з умов
надання не використовувати їх для атак
на територію Росії також зазначається що
ракета атакаус надані українцям мають
касетний боєприпас який розкидає багато
маленьких бомб здатних завдати шкоди на
великій території за оцінками інституту
вивчення війни поява атакамс в Україні
призведе до переміщення авіаційних
засобів РФ далі від лінії фронту і
швидше за все суттєво ускладнить
підтримку російською авіацією оборонних
зусиль і локальних наступальних операцій
особливо російськими гелікоптерами які
тривалий час були активними поблизу
фронту щоб послабити наступаючі
механізовані сили України передусім на
початку контрнаступу ЗСУ в червні та
липні поява ракет великої дальності
також стано новить значну загрозу для
російських складів боєприпасів у тулових
районах і ймовірно змусить російське
командування обирати між укріпленням
існуючих складів і подальшим
роззосередженням складів по всій
території окупованої України а
перебазування російських літаків на
аеродроми розташовані подалі в тилу
іймовірно створить для
повітряно-космічних сил Росії значні
проблеми з координацією і підтримкою
операцій ракети атакамс є різних
модифікацій зокрема дальністю польоту на
160 км та на 300 Україна отримала поки
Перший варіант ракета може бути оснащена
як однією боєголовкою на чверть тонни
так і касетними боєприпасами атакамс -
це ракети класу земляземля для пусків
використовуються реактивні установки
м270 ммлрс або hmarс їх Україна вже має
на озброєння для ураження російських
військ атакамис балістичні ракети вони
здіймаються в в гору і потім влучають у
ціль майже вертикально швидкість падіння
атакам з понад 3500
км/год за словами речника повітряних сил
Юрія ігната ці ракети дозволять
знищувати російські ракетні комплекси
які обстрілюють Україну з Криму зокрема
комплекс бастіон який випускає ракети
Онікс саме цими ракетами росіяни
атакували портову інфраструктуру на
півдні України Щоб завадити експортувати
зерно Україна вже використовує танські
далекобійні ракети Storm Shadow та їхній
французький аналог Утім вони не
балістичні а акрилаті і мають меншу
швидкість Крім того це ракети класу
повітря земля їх запускають із літаків
які не можуть підлітати близько до лінії
зіткнення через російське ППО а
наявність далекобійних ракет атакам з
класу земля земля значно збільшує
маневреність ЗСУ і непередбачуваність
атак пускові установки можуть непомітно
приїхати на точку запуску від
відстрілятися і одразу від'їхати така
непомітність дозволить запускати атакамс
ближче до лінії фронту тож це дозволить
Україні досягати майже всіх основних баз
які Росія використовує на окупованій
території для повітряної підтримки і
постачання своїх військ в Україні крім
того на думку глядачів на дані
американцями далекобійних ракет атакамс
має вплинути на Німеччину канцлер країни
олав шольце досі вагається і не дає
дозволу на поставки в Україну німецьких
далекобінних ракет таус зважаючи на
новини про атакамс в Україні і німецька
опозиція і члени правлячої коаліції
посилять тиск на
шольца ми як Європейський союз повинні
ще сильніше об'єднатися з нашими
трансатлантичними партнерами в НАТО в ЄС
і На мою думку Зараз ми повинні бути ще
більш рішучими в нашій допомозі Україні
Путін буде дуже радий тому що
відбувається на Близькому Сході тому що
він вважає що це відволікає увагу від
України ми хто підтримує Україну
відповідаємо на це чітко Ні це не так
Путін вже відреагував на передачу
Україні далекобійних ракет атакамс і
назвав це рішення помилкою США президент
РФ також переконаний що це кардинально
не в змозі змінити ситуацію на лінії
зіткнення втім на думку глядачів та
експертів сам факт надання ракета та
камс важливий психологічний Фактор як
для українських військових так і для
російських військ також це сигнал Кремлю
що Вашингтон і надалі буде підтримувати
Україну попри ескалацію на Близькому
Сході та посилення суперечок між
демократами І республіканцями
напередодні виборів у
США